ورحب بكم مشاهدينا وكذلك ارحب بكبير
مستشار وزاره الدفاع
البريطاني لشؤون الشرق الاوسط الفريق
التيار مارتن سامي سامسونج اهلا بك السيد
سامي معنا اييي اليوم في قناه العربيه اود
ان ابدا مقابلتي معك بسؤالك حول الملف
الاوكراني طبعا حضرتك تتابعون عن كثب كل
التطورات الميدانيه الحاصله وهناك تقارير
استخباراتيه يوميه حول هذا الموضوع كيف
تقيمون التقدم الاوكراني خاصه بعد حصول
القوات الاوكرانيه على خيرسون
شكرا
مؤشر على اخفاق روسيا في تحقيق اهدافها
واخفاق في السيطره على الشعب واخفاق في
اضعاف
في السيطره على المدينه
تحت السيطره
فعاليات على ساحه المعركه
وان هناك زخم من تكسبه اوكرانيا
وهذا يعود همم بجزء كبير من هو لدعم
الكبير الدولي
لاوكرانيا هو صراع صراع بالنسبه لروسيا
لانها غير قادره على ان تتواصل مع المجتمع
الدولي ولكن اوكرانيا قادره على هذه
العلاقه الوطيده مع المجتمع الدولي لكننا
من وجهه نظر
عسكريه همم
ان هناك معاناه انسانيه في اوكرانيا
والصعوبه
الوضع صعب
انه حساس بريطانيا
كبير هل تعتقد ان القوات الاوكرانيه
ستواصل هذا التقدم ااه وتدفع الجيش الروسي
الى الوراء تحديدا عن الضفه
الشرقيه لدهن النهر نابرو
امين
الاهداف لكننا من يضع الاهداف ليوكرانيا
نحن دورنا هو الدعم
بريطانيا
عندما يكونون بحاجه
والمدنيين الذين يكونون تحت طائل هجوم
نساعدهم دوما سيد سامي يعني هذا التراجع
او الانسحاب الروسي هل ترى بانه بريء
بمعنى هل سيقدم همم الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين كهديه ل همم
انه ربما هي مقدمه لتحركات او هجوم مضاد
اخر يحضرون له هل هنالك من مؤشرات عسكريه
حول اي تقدم ربما عكسي سيحصل بقى ايام
القادمه
واو يمشي بايظ
كحكمه في ساحه المعركه فكل
الخساره عاليه جدا
والمكتسبات
اساسيه التاليه
لكنها ايضا مؤشر على ان الاوكران قادرين
على
تحقيق الانجازات نحن في المجتمع الدولي
والدعم الدولي القوي
كلنا نستطيع ان نمنح الاكران كل الادوات
والدعم
والعسكري والمعنوي
ومواصلات الضغط
او الغربيه للجيش الاوكراني كيف تقيمون
النتائج على الارض وكيفيه استخدام واداء
الجيش الاوكراني همم لهذه الاسلحه
وتاثيرها على المعارك الميدانيه بطبيعه
الحال
طبعا
المساعده
السلاح الاهم الذي يحمله شكرا
اه اه
[موسيقى]
بدفاعهم عن وطنهم علينا ان نمنحهم الادوات
والمعدات لتحقيق ذلك ولضماني ان هذه
الادوات تستخدم
باكثر فاعليه ممكن وكفاءه
على الارض
اوروبيه قدمت
المهمه
وهذا يجعل الامر
همم مقابل هناك
وقدرات محاربه المسيارات التي تمكن الجنود
من المنوره
[موسيقى]
تحدثت عن المسيرات همم هناك ايضا حديث عن
ان روسيا همم تحصل على
مسيرات وطائرات بدون طيار مثل الطائرات
الكاميكازي هي ايرانيه الصنع كيف تقيمون
هذا التدخل الايراني في الحرب الدائره بين
روسيا واوكرانيا
بالتدخل الايراني
ثم الان هي همم تعترف بانها زودت روسيا
بالسلاح او مسيرات العلاقه بين ايران
وروسيا ليست علاقه ابديه وليست للخير بل
الخير هو في العلاقه الاوكرانيه والمجتمع
الدولي
ايران
المملكه المتحده لديها تعاون عسكري تاريخي
وقوي مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه وايضا
دوله الامارات كيف ترى سبل تطوير هذه
العلاقه العسكريه تحديدا
بياض
باننا شريك امني طويل الامل
مع السعوديه
طيب
نقوم به يوميا واسبوعيه
والان نحن نتحدث وهناك قوات
بريطانيه وجويه تساهم كثيرا بشراكه مع
الامارات ومع السعوديه
[موسيقى]
في الشرق الاوسط شكرا جزيلا لك على وجودك
هنا في قناه العربيه
وجزيل الشكر لكم مشاهدينا على حسن
المتابعه الى اللقاء